One year ago here in Mersin, smugglers' boats
were still casting off, night after night.
But their business fell away after the EU
and Turkey signed the Refugee Deal.
This smuggler tells us that only an average
of twenty people a month were willing to pay
up to 600 dollars for the clandestine passage
to Europe.
Now that disagreements between the EU and
Turkey have broken out, things have changed
again.
"Police controls and coast guard controls
have been more relaxed here the past couple
of days.
And we are suddenly receiving more requests
from refugees again.
It is very noticeable."
Have Turkey's threats to scrap the Refugee
Deal renewed Syrian refugees' hopes, here
in Mersin?
The reactions of the 300,000 refugees living
in this part of the city are mixed.
This couple from northern Syria does not want
to stay in Turkey:
"We are living from day to day.
We work in the fields once in awhile.
But we do not speak the language.
We are foreigners here."
"Back in Syria, I sold everything.
I wanted to get myself and my family away
from here."
Other Syrians will remain in Turkey, for now.
They are more interested in returning home,
than moving on to Europe.
They are critical of Turkey's current political
stance towards them.
"Turkey is using us refugees as bargaining
chips with Europe.
That's not good.
Because I would prefer to return to my home
country, as soon as it's possible."
Mersin's fishermen don't understand.
They say that most refugees have a good life
here, and that is why the smugglers' boats
stopped setting sail from here a long time
ago.
"Two years ago, they still had no work.
But now many of them have started a business.
They are often better off than us!"
Even if the Refugee Deal between Turkey and
the EU does collapse, it is unlikely that
tens of thousands of those seeking protection
would leave for the EU.
Because they are well-aware that with the
Balkan route "closed," there's very little
chance of getting any further than Greece.